we've got some info here from The New
York Times because Disney is a
struggling Disney to close Star Wars
themed hotel less than two years after
it opened the planned closure of
Galactic star Cruiser an immersive
role-playing attraction comes as Disney
seeks to cut overall costs by more than
5 billion after spending hundreds of
millions of dollars to build an
immersive Star Wars themed hotel at Walt
Disney World Disney said on Thursday
that amid sweeping corporate cost
cutting it would close the
underperforming attraction in September
only about 18 months after it opened all
visits are two night stays with a
starting cost of more than four thousand
eight hundred dollars for two people and
around 6 000 for a family of four for
authenticity the hundred cabins at the
Florida hotel have no windows instead
stars planets and asteroid showers are
shown on video screens the announcement
came as Disney pulled the plug on plans
to to build a one billion dollar office
complex in Orlando a decision said to be
influenced by the companies Feud with
Governor Ron DeSantis of Florida it was
also not long after Robert Iger in his
return as the company's chief executive
unveiled a corporate restructuring
intended to cut costs by 5.5 billion
okay real quick
I did not go to this Star Wars thing I'm
fairly certain that you guys know my
feelings on what Disney did to Star Wars
they have completely wrecked Star Wars
they have injected
wokeism into all of their properties I
canceled Disney plus I know many of you
have canceled Disney plus but the whole
implication of that and also just the
idea putting aside whether you think
they didn't mess up Star Wars they did
mess up stars or anything else
four thousand eight hundred dollars for
two nights at a hotel with no windows
what level of Rich dork would you have
to be to be doing that six thousand
dollars for a family of four that is so
profoundly insane and think how how
Disney they're supposed to be pro-family
they hate families they hate families go
to Disneyland and see how expensive
everything is you know what I mean go to
Disneyland you can go to the other Star
Wars thing that'll remain open and I
think it's called Galaxy's Edge and to
build a lightsaber a piece of crap
plastic lightsaber that lights up and
will most likely be broken by the time
you get it to the car it's like 250
bucks the whole thing is a giant croc
but the New York Times is implying that
their struggles are desantis's fault
it's not the fault that they wrecked the
Star Wars lore it's not the uh it's not
that they uh giving you a hotel with no
windows and that they're caught charging
you six thousand dollars etc etc it's
all about run this said this well we've
got a tweet here from Florida's voice
desantis's office mocks Disney for
closing the Star Wars hotel which costs
families five five thousand plus Ron
DeSantis press secretary Jeremy Redfern
this entire story was just corporate
propaganda to distract from their failed
six thousand dollar two night Star Wars
Galactic star Cruiser experiment right
at the end of the day guys you know this
everyone knows this if that thing was
good if it was worthwhile if it was fun
if it was a good use of dollars families
would still be flocking there right but
it's just not what it was right you're
overpaying for crap and that's exactly
what Disney has become
[Music]
thank you